Puhhh, bin ich geschafft vom heutigen Tag.
Liz, was ist denn heute passiert,
dass du so erledigt bist?
Ich bin heute Morgen zur Arbeit gegangen
und habe gedacht, es wird wieder so ein 08/15-Tag.
08 was?
Du hast ja bis 17.00 Uhr
gearbeitet, nicht bis 15.00 Uhr.
Nein, 08/15 heisst, dass es
ein ganz gewöhnlicher Tag war.
Ach so! Komischer Ausdruck!
Wie dem auch sei.
Ich dachte,
dass wird ein ganz normaler Tag.
Dann ist bei der Arbeit so ein Typ vorbeigekommen,
der einen Strafzettel bezahlen musste.
Er hat an einer Parkverbotszone
parkiert und musste CHF 100 bezahlen.
Ich muss zugeben, dass er ziemlich gut aussah
und meine Kollegin Nadja hat natürlich
sofort ein Auge auf ihn geworfen.
Wie bitte?
Ein Auge auf ihn geworfen? Das
muss ich falsch verstanden haben.
Nein Marcela, natürlich nicht ein richtiges Auge.
Wir sagen das, wenn wir uns für
jemanden besonders interessieren.
Ach sooo. Dachte ich mir doch,
dass das nicht stimmen kann.
Auf jeden Fall ist sie dann
auch zum Schalter gekommen.
Der Mann hat das natürlich bemerkt
und hat sofort damit angefangen,
ihr Honig ums Maul zu schmieren.
Igitt! Warum macht er denn das?
Nein! Natürlich nicht richtigen Honig.
Das ist eine Redewendung und bedeutet,
dass man sich bei jemanden einschmeicheln möchte.
Meistens, um etwas von dieser Person zu bekommen.
Ich habe den Braten natürlich gerochen
und wusste, dass er einfach den
Strafzettel nicht bezahlen wollte.
Welcher Braten denn?
Deshalb nahm ich Nadja zur Seite und sagte ihr,
dass der Mann kein wirkliches Interesse an
ihr hat, sondern sie einfach ausnutzen will.
Natürlich habe ich ihr das durch die Blume gesagt.
Hä? Welche Blume?
Puhhh, du verstehst ja wohl gar nichts!
Durch die Blume bedeutet indirekt.
Ich wollte ihre Gefühle nicht verletzten
und ihr direkt sagen, dass kein Mann
wirkliches Interesse an ihr haben kann.
Sie hat das aber nicht verstanden
und hat seinen Strafzettel gelöscht.
Ausserdem hat sie den Nachmittag blau gemacht
und ist mit ihm in ein super
schickes Restaurant gegangen.
Ach so. Und was ist dann passiert?
Ja was wohl? Das, was ich erwartet hatte.
Nadja ist in Tränen aufgelöst
zurückgekommen und hat erzählt,
dass sie ein total schönes Date hatte
und der Mann sie in ein super
schönes Restaurant ausgeführt hatte.
Danach habe er sich kurz entschuldigt,
denn er musste auf die Toilette.
Das Problem war allerdings,
dass er nie zurückgekommen ist
und sie am Ende die teure
Rechnung bezahlen musste.
Als sie die Rechnung bekam,
ist sie natürlich aus allen Wolken gefallen.
Wie bitte? Aus welchen Wolken denn?
Wieder so eine Redewendung.
Das bedeutet, dass sie total überrascht war.
Ach so, klar, wieder so eine Redewendung.
Sie hat also den ganzen Nachmittag
geweint, wie ein Wasserfall.
Ich weiss zwar,
dass sie nah am Wasser gebaut ist, aber so weinen……
Nah am Wasser gebaut?
Ach komm jetzt. Was soll das wieder heissen?
Dass sie sehr schnell und viel weint.
Aber weisst du was, genug von mir.
Erzähl mir von deinem Tag.
Mein Tag?
Mein Tag war fantastisch!
Wirklich? Warum das denn?
Weil ich einen neuen Freund habe!
Ich möchte, dass du ihn kennenlernst!
Super!
Ah,da ist er.
Liz, das ist Marco, mein neuer Freund.